these people on mainstream media they
pushed the lives relentlessly and now
they're having to walk back a little bit
here's the one guy that people seem to
think is still decent on CNN Jake Tapper
I'm not so sure about the decent part
but he's uh trying to have like a little
bit of a mayakopee here maybe
but president Trump appeared so
confident of what Durham would find he
openly pressured the special counsel to
release his findings before the 2020
election regardless the report is now
here it has dropped and it might not
have produced everything of what some
Republicans vote for it is regardless
devastating to the FBI and to a degree
it does exonerate not to a degree it
does exonerate Donald Trump it
completely exonerates Donald Trump so
even in his Maya culpa even saying the
FBI really effed this one up he's still
you know he's still shaving off the top
a little bit and I don't know what you
do with someone like Jake because I saw
when that when that clip that I just
showed you and that was going viral
yesterday people are like oh Jake Tapper
you see he gets what's going on and he's
not that terrible except if we would not
take you more than two seconds to find
roughly I don't know 500 billion clips
of Jake Tapper pushing Russia collusion
nonsense for years here's one from 2017.
I mean we could have picked any here's
just here's just an old throwback
we have some breaking news Now CNN has
learned new information about that
ongoing investigation into those
allegations raised in a collection of
memos created by a former British
intelligence agent at the time he made
the MMOs for political opponents of then
candidate Donald Trump Tim schuto and
Evan Perez have been working the story
and Jim let's start with you what
precisely have investigators learn well
Jake for the first time U.S
investigators say that they have
corroborated some of the communications
detailed in a 35-page dossier compiled
by a former British intelligence agent
CNN was first to report last month that
then president-elect Donald Trump and
President Barack Obama were briefed on
the existence of the memos prior to the
inauguration until now U.S officials
have said that none of the content or
allegations have been verified but now
multiple current and former U.S law
enforcement and intelligence officials
tell CNN that an intelligence intercepts
of foreign Nationals confirmed that some
of the conversations described in the
dossier took place between the same
individuals on the same days and from
the same locations as detailed in the
dossier we should be clear that CNN has
not confirmed the content of the calls
or whether any of the content relates to
then candidate Trump isn't it incredible
now watching that seven years later like
it was all a lie and even the way Tapper
kicks it off ongoing investigations into
allegations by a British spy it all
sounds like something without really
saying anything and then they bring on
Jim shudo and because he talks like a
newsman and we heard this from a British
spy and bro you start thinking it's real
and it was all absolute nonsense
thank you
[Music]